pour ne louper aucune vidéo abonnez-vous
et activer la petite cloche salue les
épis curieux connaissez vous la
différence entre le marron et la
châtaigne voici une châtaigne je les
ramasse et à côté de chez moi dans la
forêt elle se trouvait enveloppé dans
une bogue comme celle-ci recouverte de
piquant on en fait de bonnes soupes très
riche mais aussi d'excellentes crème et
de délicieuses friandises
mais pourquoi dans ce cas là parle-t-on
de maraude et non plus de châtaignes
pourquoi dégustons la dinde avec des
marrons et non pas des châtaignes
alors que le fruit du marronnier n'est
pas comestible
d'autant que même s'ils se ressemblent
impossible de les confondre la châtaigne
peut avoir plusieurs face plate et les
surmonter de petits poils qu'on appelle
la torche pas le marron qui vous le
voyez lui à une forme patatoïde alors
d'où vient cette confusion
en fait en cuisine le terme ma route est
utilisée pour désigner une châtaigne
bien rondes et volumineuses comme celle
ci ce terme est issu de l'italien
maroney qui signifie grosse châtaignes
comestibles du coup en france il existe
plusieurs variétés de châtaignes qu'on
appelle pas châtaignes et marrons le
marron de lure goujounac de laguépie ou
encore celui de paradis pendant très
longtemps le marron fut une nourriture
de base dans les campagnes du sud de la
france
on a fait de la farine d'ailleurs dans
certaines régions le châtaignier était
surnommé l'arbre à pain ou encore
l'arbre à saucisse car ses fruits
servette à engraisser les cochons c'est
marrant c'est marange
si vous avez aimé cette vidéo n'hésitez
pas à laisser un pouce bleus merci les
épis curieux pour les plus gourmands en
voici d'autres et pour ne rien rater
abonnez vous et activer la cloche
[Musique]